I want to join a club
and just be there
like on my steam deck yeah what's a
steam deck it's like um like valve like
steam okay they made a their own like
Nintendo switch basically yeah they did
yeah look it up steam deck is it new
it's pretty new
the computing power is absurd really
yeah it's [__] up steam deck yeah
which I know it sounds like yeah
do a steam deck on my chest someone was
playing something handheld on a flight
next to me it was probably this yeah
probably so yeah I was like is that PSP
what the [__] is that yeah so I have it
and the graphic resolution on this thing
is
insane remember this [__] of course oh
man the the pisp yeah
so what do you play on it on my steam
deck yeah
I just played sounds so funny
on my steam desk that's a ridiculous
name yeah Tetris you watch a movie yeah
I did did you like it yeah it did I
loved it yes it was pretty fun I wonder
how much of it is embellished but I mean
I read the Wikipedia afterwards it
seemed like the story was pretty
wonderful pretty not one to one I mean I
don't know how dramatic it was I'm sure
the negotiations weren't that definitely
didn't happen like that but like and I'm
sure the [__] the guy wasn't like all
snarky
to KGB operatives or whatever exactly
yeah you guys are the kings of leaving
the room yeah yeah the one doing that
but I'm sure that like going to the
Soviet Union at that time was probably
pretty nerve-wracking yeah very bold
and I mean I wonder if he actually went
there like on a tourist visa and
negotiated and like wasn't concerned
about spending the rest of his life
spoiler alert the guy who made Tetris is
dead yeah
oh what yeah I don't think he is that no
he probably isn't he's probably fine
no but uh this this is Apple TV movie
it's pretty it's pretty interesting it's
really good man but everything that is
Apple is so over polished yeah how do
they do that everything that they buy so
good everything that they produce is so
it's like oh I mean I'm saying it's not
necessarily good it's like over edited
over colored I'll tell you why because
when they
you know
I have resources close to me okay that
have provided me details right when they
go to make [__] they hire the best of
everything yeah that's what it's not
even like they're trying to be this way
in in so much as like
when they set out I mean they do like
when they set out to make stuff they
want the best of the best but because
they have the budget this is just what
happens yeah they hire
the greatest DPS the greatest directors
the greatest colorists and then this is
like this is what you get yeah movies
aren't steroids dude that's what it is
there's no there's no like grit you know
yeah it's it's like perfect films yeah
really
um I guess same thing with shrinking
have you seen that no yeah let's pull
that up
that's the one with uh Jason Siegel
it's a good show but it's almost like
I'm like I get frustrated watching it
because I'm like the writing is like too
tight the people the characters are too
cool got it too good yeah everything is
like too far it's like too fun to watch
right that it makes you frustrated
because you're like yeah you're so this
is so disconnected from reality yeah
is anything ever good enough for us are
we ever happy
I mean I enjoy I enjoy the show but
succession I mean that's one I can still
like that's a perfect show yeah yeah
absolutely perfect we should talk about
it uh spoiler alert guys Kendall dies
unfortunately Kendall uh shoots his
penis off and then bleeds out to death
yeah he kill he cuts his own balls off
with with a golf ball it's a very slow
draining sound what I know it's a I'm
sorry I'm just being violent for no
reason how would that even work
logistically maybe balls off with a golf
ball if he's beat it enough times till
the skin broke and now that wouldn't
work yeah you have to sharpen the golf
ball yeah
yeah could you cut the ball in half yeah
that's what you could do and then clamp
it down with a vise so it bends and then
yeah
twist your balls up right so the and
then just slowly saw that part off yeah
and what people don't know is your balls
actually come off like Play-Doh yeah
they're removable yeah it's just like a
piece of clay you just like girls are
always so surprised when they find that
out yeah we have different balls for
different occasions yeah right now I
have my podcast balls on yeah it's so
embarrassing when a when a young woman
is seeking to make you happy and then
she gives a little you know lick of
maroo on the on the old sack and then
[__] oops Yeah they pop off they're
like oh you hit the button like oh you
took my Mochi give that back you hit the
button yeah you hit the latch don't hit
the latch you gotta hook it back in
there we go we can continue yeah yeah
when you ever see whenever you see truck
nuts it's actually the driver hanging
his own nuts at the back of his car
exactly what is that looks like a vagina
[Laughter]
yeah truck vaginas they gotta start
making those yeah truck puss let's look
that up
look up truck vagina
just hanging a big old truck pus from
the back of the car dude
big old big old set of labia
Munch these
[Laughter]
Munch this I heard you're a Munch yeah
look it up look at a truck vagina that's
my truck [__] yep yeah
Luke do you know yes dude yes oh my God
on the toes yes let's go that is genius
no that's dangerous
beaver beaver receiver [__] yeah that's
the Midwest for you Beaver receiver
wonder how many of these like
how many of these women just walk out to
their car in some [__] degenerate man
shoving his nuts
well you remember that thinking it's a
Fleshlight just remember that video the
flashlight in the exhaust and it's like
yeah of course of course of course
that's a classic we filmed that at my
house yeah
beaver receiver I want to put one of
these on my [__] SUV and just drive
around yeah damn it there was a we saw
some some dude in a big ass truck
driving around he had a bumper sticker
that was like
straight CIS Catholic gun owner how else
can I piss you off today
[__] yeah yeah dude
[__] rules got em got em owned owned man
way to own the libs Libs owned yeah
I would have pulled him next to him and
been like hey man just wanna let you
know I'm a live and you [__] owned me
yeah yeah dude bow down I'm pissed off
right now I'm [__] upset you freaking
pissed me off yeah but yeah just beaming
at him just oh
he's like oh I bet you're so [__] mad
right yeah I'm pissed are you pissed
yeah you don't like my big diesel car
that's making you angry it was making me
so angry how many guns you got in the
back I got [__] five
oh you're so mad right now I'm peeved
you're so upset
yeah so succession success thoughts
I can't do those
yeah try it you got it my fingers are
too stiff just leave it loose
I've had practice yeah back in my
dipping days
is that a is that a prerequisite when
you go to buy the dip they're like hey
show us your no that's how you learn how
to do it though oh got it because you
smacked the top of the dip thing to make
it all packed to one side so you can
grab a nice pinch
truly that's the way it works you need a
nice compact pinch
put it right there
yeah
wrap your lip around it there's an art
to it honestly it's an art form oh yeah
no if you don't do it like that it gets
all over your mouth and then you're
swallowing little tobacco flakes it's
the worst right but if you do it nice
and get a nice pinch and then pop it in
there yeah
you're sailing this is so crazy just
like sucking on cancer fiber no I know
it's crazy it's so nice it has like
fiber like little shards of fiber
plastic in it yeah which cut your lips
so that the tobacco gets inside your
bloodstream I think I mean that might be
like an urban myth but that's what
people have always said about dip
yeah dude and if you do it too much you
get like sores why don't they just
[__] why don't they just put like
asbestos in like strawberry soda
it's like a
yeah
I guess it wouldn't get you high I don't
know I wouldn't get you high just keep
that would just give you cancer yeah
yeah which is the end goal